we have used the exponential form of a
complex number
to help us prove this cool result called
de moivre's theorem
and demarcus theorem all by itself is a
very powerful result
that we can use to help us simplify
questions uh and answer a whole bunch of
different kinds of problems that were
sort of inaccessible to us before
and this is a perfect example of that so
let's have a look at this
and see how we can do it together find
the minimum value
of the positive integer m for which
root 3 plus i to the power of m is
real or purely imaginary and then part b
says
evaluate what root 3 the plus i to the
power of m
equals for those values of n that we're
about to find
so how do we go about this well there's
a few bits of sort of
bedrock foundation we need to establish
first right they're introducing to us a
variable
m which is a positive integer so the way
that we would
write that in notation is to say m
belongs to
not just the set of integers but the set
of positive integers so that little plus
sign there
is a way to it's a shorthand way to
indicate all right we're not just
including all of the integers we're
including only the positive ones
uh to be distinguished between that and
the natural numbers like i said earlier
in a lesson a while ago some people
include 0 in that so
we're excluding 0 by saying that it's
positive
and then secondly we have this set up
over here so there is some complex
number root 3 plus i
and then it's being raised to whatever
this power m happens to be
and we want to find the values for which
it's real and purely imaginary
now even though the question doesn't
suggest it um de moivre's theorem is
going to be very useful here
because you can see the whole point here
is we're raising to a power
and de moivre's theorem gives us a very
easy way to simplify
uh you know a complex number raised to a
power that's kind of its point right
so here's the way i'm going to suggest
we begin this we want to get into uh
polar form because polar form mod arc
form is what divided by theorem is
relevant to
so it's in rectangular form at the
moment so my first
uh port of call is to actually change
this
number from rectangular form into polar
form so let's do that
so i'm going to say if z is equal to
root 3 plus i then what is it equal to
in mod arc form well what i'm going to
suggest is that you start to get used to
especially for these numbers which
are clearly set up to to give you nice
values at the end
a number like root 3 plus i you're going
to become quite familiar with actually
working out
where this is and what its values are
both in rectangular and in polar form so
if i do a quick
sketch of this right root 3 is about 1.7
so if i say
well there's 1 and there's 2 then
root 3 will be around here
and then if i say that scale is 1 so
here is where i'm going to go i should
have called that i
actually here's where i'm going to go
that's z equals root 3
plus i and so i want to work out a
modulus
and an argument for this complex number
so you can see the modulus comes from
here that's our distance to the origin
so it lives in
this right angle triangle when the sides
are 1 and root 3
you can see the modulus is going to be
the square root of
1 plus 3 which is 4. so i'm going to get
the square root of 4 which is 2.
and then i also want the argument and
i'm writing here you can see that
capital a just to remind you it's about
the principal
argument this is the angle here that i'm
interested in right so
in this one uh sorry let's let's let's
do it this way uh in this one root
three and two triangle and this is an
exact value right so it's clearly
pi on six that i'm after so now that i
have the modulus in the argument i can
rewrite z
in this form i can say it's equal to 2
of cos pi on 6
plus i sine pi on 6.
all right i've converted into polar form
and that allows me to use demarva's
theorem
to take this the the same complex number
raised to the power of m
and write it in a simpler way that will
allow this question to be very easily
solved so let's go ahead and invoke to
marvel's theorem
i will say by demarcus theorem and uh
you can either you know put the
the quote the theorem before or after
the line that involves it
i can say z to the power of m equals all
right
so z to the power of m is going to raise
this to the power of m
but it's going to multiply these
arguments by m so what i get
is 2 to the power of m times
cos of here comes demarcus theorem cos m
pi
on 6 plus i sine m
pi on 6. so this is just
the straight out use of demire's theorem
but how is it useful
to the actual question that they're
asking us right well we want to find
when this thing which is to say this
this long expression over here
when is it just real like what values of
m as
as m changes this number will change but
some particular values of m will make it
real and some of it will make some
values of m will make it purely
imaginary
i want the minimum value that's what i'm
after
the minimum value for m that gives me a
real result or a purely imaginary result
so let's now think about this
uh one at a time part one
for z of m to be real
i should say purely real
what i want is for there to be no
imaginary component right in other words
i want
the imaginary part the imaginary part of
z of m i want it to be 0. but i actually
know what the imaginary part of z
to the power of m is because of how i
wrote it up here right you can see
this this part here
is going to be the imaginary part z to
the power of
m so i can just substitute that in right
i can say
um that's sine of m
pi on 6. i want that to be zero
okay now at this point here um it pays
you can see how often we've been doing
this um throughout this topic
it really pays to be so like comfortable
with your trigonometry that
this part of the question doesn't
require too much thought but just to
remind you of what i would be thinking
and visualizing
when i see an equation like this sine of
some angle equals 0 right well there's a
lot of different angles an infinite
number in fact
of angles that if you take the sine of
those you will get 0. let me show you
what i mean
and if we draw a graph of sine like so
it's pretty messy but you get the idea
i'll do the positive heart also do this
part for illustration
and you can see all of those spots where
my sine graph
intersects with the x-axis in other
words here
here here over here and here all of
these values
sine of those angles will give me 0. so
what are these values here right well
hopefully you know your sign graph well
enough to say
that because its period is 2 pi that's a
full copy
of the graph you can kind of infer all
the rest of the values
from there so i'm going to say m pi
on 6 equals at least off of the graph
that i've got
obviously goes you know to the left and
to the right uh
to infinity but i'm going to say dot dot
dot i've got
negative 2 pi i've got negative pi
i've got 0 i've got pi i've got 2 pi
and it just keeps on going right now all
of these
will give me a value of 0 when i take
sine of them
but there's restrictions on m do you
remember that
up the top here we said m is not just
any number it's a positive integer
so therefore some of these values are
irrelevant to me
right namely these ones in here
these guys here you can't find
a positive integer m that will if you
substitute it on the left hand side give
you these particular values right
so i'm going to say but since
m is a positive
integer m pi on 6
has to equal only pi 2 pi
and so on these ones are okay so i'm not
solving for n pi on 6. i'm trying to
solve for m
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
multiply both sides by
6 on pi that should cancel everything
out for me
so hopefully you can convince yourself
that you've got 6 12
and so on these are the values of m all
of them that will make
the z to the power of m purely real
because i don't want all the values i
just want the smallest
value i think that's what i said the
minimum value there so if i'm just going
to write that down the bottom here the
minimum value is the smallest one that i
wrote down
the minimum m equals six so we'll come
back to this result
in a second but for now that's part one
i have solved
for m that's the smallest value at least
i think that will make zdm
purely real